all right so let's move on to part b now
when you have a look at part b you'd be
forgiven for thinking hold on a second
is this deja vu because the question
begins by saying using integration by
parts on a n or otherwise show that and
then they give you some different result
you might be thinking hold up did i not
just use integration by parts on a n
wasn't that what we were doing right
here you can see i said well if i want
to get to this the way i'm going to do
is by breaking it apart with you and atv
and then off i go now the answer is yes
that is exactly what you did but as you
know number one generally speaking but
number two specifically for integration
by parts one of the best things and most
challenging things about mathematics is
when you have a single question or a
single concept or mathematical object
and what you need to do is determine
well which angle which perspective
should i take on this object and in fact
one of the key ways to make mathematical
progress is to take the same object and
look at it from different angles from
different perspectives
when we have to think about integration
by parts this is kind of baked into the
idea because you have to choose you and
choose dv and you could make different
choices you could say for example for
something that's obviously you know and
something times something else you could
just switch them and say well i'll make
them u and dv or dv and u right that's
one obvious you know switch around but
that's not the only way especially with
questions like this there's an infinite
number of ways to break up say for
example
a n there's a cos the 2n x
this term in different ways you can
break it up we chose to break up into a
cos and a close to the 2n minus one uh
in this first instance but what we're
going to do is choose to break it up a
different way
and that's going to give us the result
that they want for part b and
hold on to hats this is the second time
we're going to do integration by parts
it's definitely not going to be the last
so let's have a think about this
i note that in the result that i'm
required to prove right here okay you
can see there is this cos to the 2n
minus 1
x appearing right now because that
result appears in the integrand i'm
either going to get to it by
differentiation or integration just like
i did in part a it's a smaller number
than 2n it's 2n minus 1. so that's a
good bet to think it's going to come by
a differentiation but what's the
appropriate thing to differentiate well
back here we said
if you differentiate a 2n minus 1 that
will get you to 2 and minus 2 because
that was the goal in that particular
question but my goal is different now i
want to get to a 2n minus 1. so
therefore it stands to reason that a
likely thing i would have come from is
one more than this so close to the 2n x
now in a n i already have a cos 2 in x
just to remind you right this is the
integral from 0 to pi on 2
of cos 2n x dx so you might say well if
i'm going to use that whole thing in the
integrand to get to this if that's going
to be my u to give me my du1 dx here
what will be my dv
and the answer is we're going to pull
out an old trick that we've used before
which is to say that anything
even things that don't necessarily look
like products can be written as a
product you just have to stick a one
there right one times something it's
still a product that we can use
integration by parts on now there's
another clue in the question why not
just that you look at this and think it
differentiates down to this there's
another clue in the question that tells
you that you want a 1 in there which is
have a look at the rest of the integrand
do you notice there is
an x term appearing well just like
before it's going to come via
differentiation or integration
in this case
there's not from from a n anyway there's
no x squared term that's going to
differentiate down into x so we've
correctly chosen this as the thing to
differentiate down into in order to get
this x we're going to have to go there
by our integration so that 1 which i've
stuck in there is going to integrate up
into the x that you can see here and
that sine x is going to come from the
rest of our um you know use of reverse
chain rule and things like that okay
so um i think we've put enough
foundation down let's have a go at a n
equals i'm going to write it as naught
to pi on 2
of 1 times cos to the 2n x
dx okay
just like before i'm going to break this
up into its different components so i'll
do this in another color just to make it
clear right
i'll use my as discussed my cos to the
2n x is my u that gives me a d u on dx
of okay inside function outside function
the inside function is cos so what
you're going to get from that is a minus
sign x this feels familiar
and then the outside function is
something raised to the power of 2n so
therefore that power comes out the front
and then i reduce the power by 1. and
you can see you're like oh look i have
already so many other pieces that i want
here right i've got an x there it is
i've got a sine sorry not an x i've got
a sine x there i'll get the x in a
second i've got the cos the 2n minus 1 x
here and i even have the 2n which is
going to end up out the front there so i
might just highlight that 2n there it's
going to come from that 2n right there
okay so this is looking good it's very
promising we're just the u and du let's
do
dv
and v okay so as promised we chose one
for this one and then you integrate that
up
i misspoke before this is where the x
appears
i should i'll put that in purple because
that's what i colored it before
you can see that link right in
there
done okay so i've got it all set up
let's now actually just take this result
here and continue the working so this
equals and i'll just
draw that straight down
okay what do we get we'll start with the
uv so
definite integral and my u and my v will
give me x
cos the two x i'm still from north to pi
on 2. we're going to pull a very similar
trick here um to what we did in part a
but i'll hit pause on that we'll return
to it take away the integral of naught
pi on t
and now i'm doing vdu right so you can
see this is where my
x is going to combine with this and it's
all going to look pretty nice right so
here comes my v and then here comes all
the rest of the stuff so i'm just going
to grab all of this
you'd better be careful though because
that
minus sign x is actually being
multiplied
there we go and of course we're
integrating with respect to x right
okay let's talk about that trick we're
going to pull before
this when you evaluate the lower
boundary at zero that's going to be zero
and then a different color this when you
up
integrate and substitute in the upper
boundary that's going to be zero so
everything from our first term here this
definite integral this is all going to
collapse into 0. i've got a double
negative here and then this
constant coefficient of 2n just needs to
be pulled out the front and that's the
result that i'm required to prove so in
fact i'm just going to go there and say
0
plus
2n and then everything else just really
follows right from naught to pi on 2
what have i got here x
sine x
cos
2 n minus 1 x dx just take a quick pick
up does that look good i'm pretty happy
with that i'm even going to leave that 0
plus at the front because i think it's
trivially
simple to have to write the next line
okay
so part b
not so hard um maybe because our brain
is kind of already in integration by
parts mode and that's why you can see
you know this is one mark and you
believe you got one mark just for using
this very sophisticated technique but uh
it's because it's it's so familiar based
on part a